[Musique]
il a 34 ans mais n'a-t-il pas déjà vécu
plusieurs vies plus jeunes pensionnaire
du français plus jeunes césarisé dans la
catégorie meilleur acteur est déjà une
trentaine de films capables de toujours
il est le double de Michel Gondry à
l'écran et interprétera bientôt en
costume le Comte de Monte-Cristo
conquérant Hollywood et passer à la
réalisation font à sa portée on arrête
plus Pierre Niner qui est en aparté
bonsoir fier Ninet bonsoir bienvenue en
aparté merci et de deux entre nous et de
deux bienvenue à vous bienvenue dans mon
oreille
et oui une nouvelle rencontre vous
m'aviez fait quelques frayeurs la
dernière fois parce que vous êtes joueur
évidemment qu'est-ce qu'on avait fait
avec les flammes du studio si vous
pouvez pas flirter avec les flammes pour
moi c'est que c'est pas la peine de
faire une interview il faut pouvoir
danser avec les flammes évidemment ça
vous va bien alors vous n'aviez pas de
lunettes à ce moment-là qu'est-ce que
vous avez changé je regarde parce que
nous aussi on a changé des choses vous
avez repéré ou pas la déco déjà moi je
vois que c'est toujours un petit peu un
trip mégalo catastrophique j'imagine que
c'est chez moi bonsoir bah bien
installe-toi ouais c'est l'Odyssée
j'adore j'ai joué dedans en fait ouais
ma photo est Gondry tous mes films viens
voir bah viens voir
là c'est la honte oh là j'ai tapé une
caméra tout de suite pardon non non non
arrêtez le coup
il y a aucune photo de
si si il y a une photo de moi un endroit
ouais mais c'est moi avec des avec
d'autres gens des gens que j'aime bien
d'accord
je vais voir si je suis encore faire ça
d'un an sur l'autre je suis plus sur des
moments
viens si pas mal mais vous vous
entraînez et dites-le non non mais parce
que effectivement il faut savoir que
Pierre Niney est passé à très peu de
choses du parquet par du parquet pro du
parquet oui vous voulez dire
du parquet évidemment
tellement loin du parquet pro que en
fait c'est une grande vanne avec mes
potes un jour j'ai eu le malheur de dire
j'aurais pu jouer en Pro B parce que
j'adore le basket et ce jour là
peut-être je venais de faire un bon
match je le croyais un tout petit peu au
fin fond de ma tête dans un moment de
déni de réalité totale mais depuis ces
gens running gag tous mes potes
bon pierre vous êtes un homme pressé je
sais que vous avez un emploi du temps
hyper chargé on va se parler franchement
d'abord de Michel Gondry du film du
moment est-ce que vous voulez vous
asseoir confortablement dans un des
fauteuils voilà ouais par exemple vous
m'indiquez ici mais pas du tout en fait
vous êtes un locataire habitué récurrent
les crêpes ça fonctionne toujours
j'adore bon alors ce film Le livre des
solutions nouveau nouvel œuvre de Michel
bondry en salle de bain vous y partagez
la fiche avec Blanche Gardin Frankie
wallache Françoise Lebrun tellement
attachante ou encore Vincent de base je
pitch ou vous pitcher moi je peux
essayer après il manque des choses vous
me complétez allez
et bah c'est l'histoire d'un réalisateur
bon très très inspiré d'un épisode de la
vie de Michel Gondry qui va voir ses
financiers et producteurs le lâchips
qu'il n'aime pas du tout ce qu'il est en
train de tourner et du coup il va se
réfugier se cacher avec les rushs de son
film chez sa tante en plein milieu des
Cévennes et à partir de là ces tempêtes
sous un crâne puisque il est entre ses
coups de génie et ses coups de folie
puisqu'il va découvrir quand même qu'il
est atteint de bipolarité et que donc il
a des moments il pense avoir des idées
absolument géniales en filmant une
fourmi ou en transformant un camion en
salle de montage et c'est le camion Taj
et du coup on va suivre qu'est-ce que ça
peut être d'être d'avoir des troubles
mentaux et d'essayer de gérer avec ça
alors qu'on doit déjà gérer un énorme
film et un tournage bon vous êtes
parfait je vous embauche extrait c'est
parti bande-annonce
chanter quelque chose ça sera plus
naturel chanter
c'est comme ça qu'on fait des films
ça vous plaît pas on arrête le tournage
plan B oui plan B on va finir le montage
et la tente de marque
désolé de vous embêter avec ça à donner
il faut être patiente et l'aider à
retrouver son chemin et fait un
documentaire sur une fourmi
ça fait deux jours qui fait que ça il
faut démarrer son projet comme on
démarre une voiture en hiver le livre
des solutions c'est quoi le livre des
solutions
le livre des solutions devait être un
recueil de réponse à tous les conflits
mon chef-d'œuvre
[Musique]
qui s'était arrêté au titre
démarre ton projet fais ce que tu veux
bienvenue dans ton camion Tage tu
tournes le volant à droite et pour
couper tu claques
[Musique]
vraiment bien ton film et à l'arrière on
installe les producteurs ils peuvent
rien voir des producteurs
c'est du jamais vu si c'est du jamais vu
c'est peut-être que c'est pas une bonne
idée
vous allez interpréter mon corps c'est
tout simple
ça va aller tu t'en sors bien
ouais vous vous en sortez bien mais
disons que c'est vrai qu'il y a du chaos
ils sont pas cela dedans vous êtes hyper
décontracté j'adore pose là c'est un peu
la pose de aujourd'hui
ou de nu de nuit et de nues non surtout
de nuit non non je vais pas vous mentir
je vais pas vous vendre des trucs vous
serez déçu envoyer en film mais non non
je suis aussi décontracté ceci dit je me
sens à la maison évidemment ce film il
est savoureux et il se passe plein de
choses c'est très singulier il y a du
doute il y a du stress et une comico
dramatique en quelque sorte c'est ça
que Michel Gondry a vraiment traversé je
trouve qu'il y a une vraie générosité un
vrai courage à parler aujourd'hui pour
lui de ce moment-là où il était sur un
gros film en plus avec des des acteurs
importants et tout et il a commencé à
vriller et qu'est-ce que c'est que
vriller quand on a cette responsabilité
artistique économique sur les épaules et
aussi pour dire aux gens aujourd'hui
ces problèmes là ces troubles mentaux en
fait ils sont courants vous pouvez en
avoir et vous avez le droit d'en avoir
il y a pas de honte à en avoir et c'est
c'est humain et du coup moi j'étais
content de faire de la comédie sur un
truc aussi important aujourd'hui et
aussi sérieux entre guillemets que de
dire n'ayez pas honte n'ayez pas peur et
surtout comme Michel Gondry vous pouvez
traverser un tunnel donc vous avez
l'impression que c'est interminable et
que c'est le pire moment de votre vie et
en même temps 15 ans plus tard arrivé à
le sublimer ou en retirer des choses
positives et avoir à revoir la lumière
et aujourd'hui Michel il a fait un film
à propos de ça un film super intime donc
je trouve très courageux quand même sur
ce sujet et vous comment on fait pour
être Michel Gondry pour l'incarner sans
limiter pour pas forcer le trait pour
être toujours subtil je sais que c'était
déjà un enjeu très fort pour vous pour
Yves Saint Laurent et là oui non labo
pas du tout dans la même optique là
Michel déjà voulait pas d'imitation il
voulait pas que j'essaie de marcher ou
parler comme lui mais néanmoins je
l'avais sous les yeux comme maintenant
tous les jours sur le plateau de
tournage donc c'était assez évident que
j'essaie de lui voler des trucs et que
j'essaie de comprendre que j'essaie de
comprendre dans quelle démarche il était
ce qui m'a ce qui m'a servi c'est pas
mal les vidéos aussi de lui à l'époque à
l'époque où il a déraillé un peu on va
dire et en fait de comprendre
de comprendre par exemple il m'a envoyé
les vidéos du moment où effectivement il
avait décidé de faire la BO de son film
la musique du film alors il a pas de
notion de chef d'orchestre voilà mais il
s'est dit je vais diriger moi
l'orchestre professionnel mais je vais
le diriger avec mon corps comme ça voilà
ça ce sera la caisse claire ça ce sera
les violons ça ce sera voilà et à partir
de ça il leur a donné la règle du jeu à
tous les musiciens en prenant vraiment
la place du chef d'orchestre qui était
parti et très énervé comme on le voit
dans le film et il s'est mis à diriger
l'orchestre comme ça et ça il m'a envoyé
la vidéo et ça c'est ce qu'on a
reproduit dans le film assez de façon
assez identique assez fidèle et ça c'est
tout le génie de Michel Gondry et il
faut dire que Michel Gondry et vous
c'est une longue histoire on va y
revenir dans un petit instant mais je
voudrais quand même aller sur un point
parce que vous parliez de cette
bipolarité effectivement le personnage
il est contrarié nerveux colérique
autoritaire mais aussi attachant inspiré
bon bipolaire on l'a dit vous quand vous
embrassez ce rôle vous pourriez aussi
avoir ces excès dans la vie
oui je pense que je peux être très
impatient je pense que je peux être j'ai
pu être je le suis plus trop mais enfin
je suis moins parce que j'ai travaillé
dessus donc bravo pierre merci
obsessionnel aussi c'est à dire de
passionnés à obsessionnel il peut y
avoir qu'un pas l'obsession quand elle
gagne trop elle l'entame l'efficacité du
travail en fait finalement et donc on en
a pas vraiment besoin parce que parce
que ça devient parasitaire donc oui je
pense que j'ai pu avoir ce côté
obsessionnel que Marc Michel Gondry a
dans le film
mais
je pense aussi que je partage avec lui
pas que des défauts mais de la fantaisie
quoi l'amour de la fantasy c'est un truc
que je partage avec Michel et on s'adore
pour ça mais cette révélation elle est
aussi liée à votre
à votre rencontre à tous les deux plus
de 10 ans maintenant oui oui alors j'ai
demandé d'être mon parrain à une soirée
une soirée des César où j'étais prénommé
dans les espoirs et
contre toute attente il est venu et
j'étais
plein de projets et tout je m'attendais
pas du tout à ce que Michel Gondry
débarque et il a débarqué je me rappelle
alors lui il dit non mais moi je me
rappelle très bien il avait un
attaché-case et un ciré jaune quand il
est arrivé on aura un peu dit gros mythe
donc voilà c'est gros mythe et bah c'est
une belle période physiquement pour moi
j'étais content et puis et puis non et
puis c'était une super soirée bah les
premières questions je vais parler de
Jim Carrey puis on a parlé de Kate
Winslet d'Eric et Ramzy on a parlé de
Jack Black qui est dans bkin rewind
c'était trop cool et puis depuis on a
gardé un peu le contact jusqu'à ce que
12 ans plus tard je croyez dans vos
rêves et là pareil vous en mettez enfin
vous vous n'y croyez pas à ce moment-là
quand vous recevez la j'étais dans un
moment de ma vie un peu une tempête sous
un crâne moi aussi et il m'a proposé ce
film et je me suis dit
à cette époque là pour être tout à fait
honnête j'ai la force de rien je pensais
même pas que j'allais refaire un film
dans les deux ans à venir je voulais
juste du repos et c'était Michel et
c'était ce script là et ça parlait aussi
de choses qui m'intéressaient du coup de
cet épuisement et tout et
de l'acte créatif de ce que ça coûte et
de ce que ça peut offrir aux gens mais
aussi de ce que ça coûte alors le timing
était là ce film il est en salle il faut
aller le voir le livre des solutions en
salle de bain pour être exacte vous
voulez bien vous installer très
confortablement dans le fauteuil marron
qui se trouve près des toits de Paris
parce que vous avez quitté Paris pour la
campagne il y a déjà un moment parce que
vous voyez là il y a l'horizon un peu
que moi j'ai à la campagne c'est à dire
on voit loin et d'avoir un horizon c'est
important je crois c'est ça qui me
manquait au bout d'un moment en ville et
mais les toits de Paris j'ai une
infection particulière parce que j'ai
passé du temps aussi quand j'étais
adolescent
je j'ai fait un peu les 400 coups sur
les toits de Paris je ne le recommande
pas c'est dangereux non mais les 400
coups tiens parlons-en c'est un peu le
film qui illustre ce propos si vous
voulez bien appuyer sur la télécommande
que vous maîtrisez parfaitement
qu'est-ce qu'il y a qu'est-ce que tu
veux
non
Jacquie et Michel c'est très très bon
non c'est pas ça non rien
border bukake avec des vestes
[Musique]
va voir dans le frigo je t'ai mis une
petite surprise c'est vrai ouais c'est
quoi tu as pas vu non va voir tu me
régales
pas longtemps 2016 déjà pourtant ça a
l'air d'être hier film premier film
d'ailleurs d'Igor Gotman five votre pote
de longue date vous avez fait casting
ensemble sur Canal François civil aussi
qu'on aperçu en fait c'est 5 potes
d'enfance qui réalise leurs rêves vous
vous leur permettez vous vous permettez
à tous de vivre en coloc jusqu'au jour
parce que vous payez votre papa paye une
partie du loyer jusqu'au jour où ça
fonctionne plus franchement comme ça il
faut trouver une solution vous
improvisez dealer alors il y a Fanny
Ardant Pascal de melon au casting il y a
des scènes incroyables
il y a deux choses que je me demandais
comment on gère d'abord
est-ce qu'il y a une forme de fraternité
sur un film de bandes comme ça avec des
mecs du même âge ils ont du succès c'est
possible ça
complètement ouais c'était un peu l'idée
de ce film aussi c'était de faire un
film quand on avait encore l'âge et pour
l'avoir dans notre filmographie et se
dire on l'a fait ensemble c'était
cool c'était des années encore d'un
souci moi j'étais pas encore papa donc
j'avais pas cette nouvelle casquette qui
est quand même une responsabilité donc
il y avait une forme de ouais d'un souci
de légèreté dans l'idée de faire ce film
mais les égaux les égaux ils sont là
vous êtes tous des comédiens déjà
reconnu ouais mais non enfin oui mais on
est tous potes avant d'être avant de de
enfin je sais pas on est on est tous on
est tous liés par un truc de
de complicité très fort et puis c'est un
vrai plaisir de se dire que on fait ce
film là que en fait le vrai plaisir
aussi en fait évidemment c'est toujours
le public c'est c'est quand même le boss
du début à la fin aujourd'hui le public
les jeunes surtout moi des jeunes de 15
16 17 18 ans ont vu ce film et aussi des
répliques et tout c'est génial si je
peux avoir fait ce passage là moi
maintenant j'ai 34 donc je suis plus
vraiment proche d'eux en âge mais si ce
film il a pu traverser un peu de grandes
soeurs à petit frère petit frère à
petite sœur c'est un accomplissement
génial d'ailleurs ça fonctionne
tellement que il y a fiasco là qui
arrive toujours avec
une série oui encore et François et moi
jouons encore un binôme dans dans le
film de potes un peu avec un des deux
qui est un peu bancal et on s'est régalé
à tourner ça ça sera sur Netflix bientôt
l'année prochaine et puis et vraiment on
a retrouvé les grandes rigolades de
l'époque et je pense qu'on ouais j'ai
envie qu'on propose un truc de ouais de
comédie qui qui va aussi loin que nos
délires quoi donc voilà on a essayé de
faire ça est-ce que c'est aussi ce film
ou effectivement vos aventures communes
à tout cela c'est une sorte de
rattrapage parce que peut-être il y a eu
un moment le sentiment d'avoir sacrifié
des choses pour l'amour de l'art quand
vous pouviez être en tournée sur du des
textes classiques alors qu'il y avait
des Colocs justement ou des voyages à
l'étranger entre potes
ouais là je pense que moi j'ai travaillé
très vite avec des vieux quand je dis
vieux c'est pas méchant mais à l'époque
c'était des vieux pour moi c'est des
gens qui allaient sans des acteurs qui
avaient 50 ans en tournée province à
Rouen à Lens alors que moi mes potes
médias tu viens pas à New York
finalement parce que on y va machin truc
puis après on va San Francisco non non
j'ai encore des dates au Havre donc en
vrai j'adorais ça parce que je faisais
déjà le métier que j'adorais mais c'est
vrai que j'avais 18 19 ans et que du
coup moi je suis impression d'être un
peu passé à côté du moment des Colocs de
la fac et tout et en même temps
j'ai eu la chance de ne pas avoir
peut-être l'après que ont eu de
je fais quoi de ma vie mais c'est pas ça
que je veux faire mais j'ai passé je
suis dans cette école et en fait je sais
pas pourquoi je fais du droit et que
j'apprends des trucs par cœur et c'est
j'ai pas eu ce vertige là mais du coup
parfois me retrouver avec des des gars
sur des tournages et en profiter pour
tourner des conneries comme on peut le
faire avec avec Jonathan Cohen sur la
flamme ou le flambeau ou alors sur
fiasco qui sera sur Netflix bientôt
c'est un rêve c'est génial alors on
essaie de faire les choses
rigoureusement et de faire une belle da
et une belle Réal et de raconter des
choses qui ont du sens pour nous quand
même mais c'est quand même la connerie
qui prime et quand je dis la connerie je
dis ça avec toute la l'affection et tout
les lettres de noblesse que ça peut
avoir parce que moi je suis persuadé que
la connerie ça peut être sublime que le
ridicule ça peut être génial et que la
médiocrité peut être belle alors là on
va parler de sens aussi même si j'ai
l'impression qu'il faut que je pète un
câble comme François Cluzet c'est
l'impression que j'ai l'impression
vous êtes libre vous savez que vous êtes
chez vous il y a un bail des derniers
prennent mal François apparemment par
amour bien sûr il vient nous voir
incessamment très bien
je vous en supplie je vous en supplie
[Musique]
sur le
bouton
mais on y va
ah voilà waouh changement d'ambiance
moi c'est pas mal ça de la plus fun
ou le plus costaud mais justement
j'aimais l'idée que ce métier puisse me
rendre fort
sûr de moi
[Musique]
cette photo qui est derrière moi
date d'il y a 10 ans
lors de mon incorporation à la brigade
il y a eu cette accident
et
j'ai voulu aider mes hommes ils
m'entendait plus je suis allé les
chercher
voilà j'ai
accompli ma mission
j'ai sauvé et j'ai péri
effectivement sauver ou périr 2022 donc
là récemment Frédéric Tellier vous jouez
ce sapeur-pompier de Paris la scène est
hyper puissante évidemment vous votre
investissement il l'est aussi vous avez
pris 10 kg de muscles vous allez maigrir
ensuite pour le film toujours alors il y
a la préparation physique mais il y a
aussi il y a aussi bien entendu le
propos le fond le sens tout était
extrêmement vibrant dans ce dans ce film
dans cette responsabilité aussi bah moi
j'ai adoré enfin cette expérience a été
franchement transformative pour moi
passer ce temps avec la BSPP découvrir
vraiment le quotidien des
sapeurs-pompiers à Paris les accidents
auxquels ils sont confrontés les
suicides les gens les gens qui vont mal
les gens qui ont mal
et encore une fois la devise des
sapeurs-pompiers
je ne vais pas te demander d'où tu viens
je ne vais pas te demander ce que tu
fais je ne vais pas te demander quelle
est ta religion si je te demande
pourquoi tu as mal c'est simplement pour
mieux te soigner bon c'est évidemment un
humanisme qui est qui est louable
magnifique l'idée était de d'étudier un
peu qu'est-ce que ça peut être la
souffrance derrière cet engagement
la souffrance surtout quand on vient
parcours comme ce jeune pompier Franck
ce que je retiens quand même beaucoup
aussi de sauver ou périr c'est à quel
point il y a aucun moyen dans les
services publics parce qu'ils ont pas
les moyens de travailler les pompiers et
ça ça m'a choqué vraiment quoi ils sont
mal payés ils font beaucoup d'heures ils
travaillent dans des conditions
dangereuses et aujourd'hui c'est j'aime
bien de temps en temps aussi faire des
films pour me dire ok je si ce message
peut passer d'une manière ou d'une autre
ça fera peut-être rien bouger mais c'est
l'endroit où je suis moi je joue des
personnages c'est vraiment pas grand
chose mais bon quitte parfois faire des
films aussi pour pour faire passer des
choses on croit ou des petites choses
qui nous révoltent les sapeurs-pompiers
de Paris l'hôpital public l'éducation
nationale c'est ces gens-là qui
devraient être les mieux lotis puisque
ils font des choses tellement vitales
importantes on a parlé récemment avec le
covid des choses essentielles et non
essentielles bon tant qu'ils seront pas
payés comme des gens essentiels et tant
qu'ils auront pas le temps de travail
c'est-à-dire en fait des moyens c'est
toujours la même chose
étant qu'on entendra des ah il faut pas
privatiser quand même ce sera toujours
un problème vous voyez finalement je le
fais mon quart d'heure
j'ai juste un petit un petit coup de
gueule pour les services publics parce
que parce qu'ils sont exangs et qu'ils
arrêtent pas de le dire et qu'en fait ça
a pas assez d'impact pas assez de
répercussions donc je continuerai à
faire des films sur les professeurs et
je continuerai à faire des films sur
l'hôpital public
je vous invite à vous déplacer vers la
bibliothèque pour nous choper un petit
truc dans une seconde et en chemin quand
même il y a une façon sombre de Pierre
Niney il y a un truc que vous que vous
repoussez d'un revers de la main qui est
pas pour vous qui est c'est à dire pas
pour moi
votre façon ouais il y a une faiblesse
perniche chez Pierre Niney je pense
qu'on a tous une façon on a une époque
étrange où presque cette façon parfois
il faudrait prétendre qu'elle existe pas
on est au carrefour d'un truc parce que
j'ai l'impression qu'aujourd'hui cette
façon
il faudrait qu'elle n'existe pas et par
ailleurs il y a aussi quelque chose de
un vrai progrès qui est il faut assumer
que c'est humain et qu'on a tous aussi
des choses un peu plus dégueulasses à
l'intérieur de nous et en fait moi j'ai
envie de faire des films qui parlent pas
que des choses chouettes mais qui
parlent aussi de cette part de
dégueulasse parce qu'en fait je pense
que c'est vital voilà je vois un livre
d'Hitchcock ça parle de nos dégueulasses
notre envie notre envie de voir le
dégueulasse de l'humain le monstrueux ne
nous en délecter parfois et parfois d'en
avoir peur et on raconte aux enfants des
histoires qui font un peu peur parce
qu'ils aiment bien avoir un peu peur
alors il faudrait pas en arriver à une
époque on jugerait les adultes parce
qu'ils ont aussi envie d'avoir un peu
peur et de voir du dégueulasse c'est
cathartique depuis la nuit des temps on
a besoin de ça donc oui j'espère avoir
une façon j'espère même l'avoir
entretenue en ayant regardé du Tim
Burton un peu jeune et j'espère aussi
ne pas être jugé par mes mes
contemporains mes pères et mes
concitoyens quand j'ai envie de regarder
en fait entrer l'accusé ou quand j'ai
envie de lire une une tragédie de
Richard III où il bute tout le monde et
empoisonne tout le monde c'est par
sombre elle existe dans l'humain elle
nous fascinera toujours mais par contre
si on se dit qu'aujourd'hui il faut plus
mettre ça en avant qu'il faut mettre
plutôt les choses bien les choses les
choses plus dans l'ordre de la morale
bah le risque en fait c'est que le petit
le petit démon qu'on a en chacun de nous
au lieu de le faire sortir et de et
justement de le partager ensemble et de
se dire ça fait partie de notre humanité
pourquoi comment comment
faire pour que ça reste à l'état de
fantasme et non pas et non pas que ça
devienne un truc qu'on enfouie qu'on
cache et donc en fait qui va qui va
rester à l'intérieur et qui va ressortir
de manière on l'a déjà vu l'histoire
nous la raconter c'est que des cycliques
on peut pas raconter un monde de
bisounours parce que le monde n'est pas
un monde de bisounours donc oui j'espère
avoir une par sombre et presque j'ai
envie de vous dire quelque part je
l'entretiens aussi de manière saine de
manière équilibrée mais je pense qu'il
faut pas se refuser à ce monde là donc
oui oui là par sombre et oui je pense en
avoir une et je pense aussi que c'est
j'ai déjà plein de moments de ma vie où
j'allais moins bien et que voir très mal
et que j'espère pouvoir mettre ça au
service aujourd'hui de mon art et de mon
jeu et c'est ce que j'ai essayé de faire
dans le livre des solutions de Michel
Gondry alors ce livre des solutions de
Michel Gondry il est dans les salles
demain en attendant vous l'avez vu la
guitare vous lui avez tourné autour la
guitare la guitare elle vous démange
une grosse apparemment
je l'avais dit
médiator mais non mais enlevez-moi ce
médiator pitié mais qu'est-ce que vous
voulez que je joue je sais pas je sais
pas jouer grand chose moi vous avez joué
Sting sur les réseaux la France entière
le monde entier s'en est emparé
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que je peux vous jouer mais je
sais pas quoi mais je suis pas très moi
j'aime bien jouer mais je suis pas très
bon
du il y a plein de choses que vous jouez
ou vous détournez
[Musique]
non mais je sais pas très bien jouer il
y a plein de trucs que je sais pas très
bien faire ça a été une grande question
pour moi c'est je sais pas très bien de
faire mais je prends du plaisir à le
faire est-ce que je dois continuer il y
a tout un moment j'étais très
perfectionniste et je me disais non faut
pas que je continue parce que ça arrive
à rien tant que si je suis pas si je
suis pas Tiger Wood en golf ça sert à
rien si je suis pas Michael Jordan en
basket pourquoi je joue et puis
maintenant je me dis bah en fait
en fait on va tous mourir et peut-être
pas si grave de prendre un peu de
plaisir à faire un truc pas très bien
[Musique]
voilà magnifique c'est du Clapton
malheureusement pour son fils qui l'a vu
disparaître merci merci pour ce moment
pierre
évidemment vous êtes un homme pressé ça
on le sait donc j'ai envie de vous
présenter
la seule avantage de l'âge peut-être on
a un cadeau pour vous regarder demi-tour
top top voilà encore un peu à droite
légèrement en biais dans l'angle du
canapé ce serait pratique
où ça quoi dans l'angle du canapé bien
chaud voilà c'est parfait un cadeau pour
vous
on espère que vous avez gardé le
précédent
pardon je m'excuse mais je vous dois la
vérité
ça a l'air pas mal
bien joué qu'est-ce que c'est ça
c'est un jouet
mais c'est trop gentil mais vous en avez
compris
un autre donc je suis en recherche je
suis en recherche de chien si je puis
dire et en fait le problème c'est que
moi ça ne s'arrête pas c'est à dire que
je pourrais maintenant que je suis à la
campagne en plus je pourrais en avoir 30
oh là là vous avez dit que dans une
autre vie vous pourriez être éleveur
canin peut-être franchement je crois que
j'aurais aimé ça c'est marrant parce
qu'on tournait avec des chiens loups sur
monte cristaux
avant-hier et il y avait un grand
dresseur français et je parlais une
heure et demie avec lui et voilà des
chiens non je sais pas j'adore
j'adore les chiens pas très original
mais quand vous roulez dans l'herbe avec
votre chien tout ça ouais carrément fait
des grandes balades et tout
j'adore les chiens j'adore les chiens
depuis Didier aussi je sais pas si j'ai
pas vu shabbat évidemment
on se fait ça à la 3e
mais vous revenez bah je reviendrai avec
plaisir pour pour monter cristaux bah
tant qu'à faire
un petit truc à nous escalquer bien sûr
une petite
vous avez déjà vu une balle de basket
dans le feu non mais non ah elle
traverse elle traverse on peut pas
l'empêcher non plus les gens veulent du
chaud les gens veulent du spectacle et
vous êtes pas les empêcher j'adore quand
vous vous en parler de l'espace
j'ai plus peur
filet vers la sortie le livre des
solutions vous attend parce que ça sort
demain vous êtes excellent évidemment
savoureux en Michel Gondry blanche
Gardin Franky wallache Françoise Lebrun
Vincent Elbaz vous entoure
le film qui n'est pas indifférent c'est
le moins que l'on puisse dire j'espère
que les gens vont beaucoup courir parce
qu'à Cannes ça a beaucoup beaucoup
rigolé chez mon plus beau souvenir d'un
festival et le cadeau quand même vous
l'embarquez ou pas je plaisante bien sûr
je vous embrasse merci à bientôt et
plein de bonnes choses pour le film
ouais c'était cool merci pour les
cadeaux
c'est trop mignon ce petit jouet pas du
tout s'il va jouer avec
[Musique]